If you need a hall pass, let me know now
before we get started please.
School choice is a hot-button issue, but I fear that
much of the back-and-forth misses the
real promise of school choice. The
real promise of school choice is not
the assurance that it will somehow
magically raise reading and math scores.
Though, let me note, that the most
rigorous evaluations of charter schools
suggest that their students do as well
or better than their peers. The real
promise of school choice is the
opportunity for educators to create the
kinds of schools that can best serve
their kids in today's America.
Reform-minded educators, who are trying
to create new programs or launch new
schools in a traditional system, run into
a wall presented by school boards and
central administrators, and wary
communities. This is frustrating, it can be
intimidating, and it's frequently a
dead-end. School choice is not an attack
on traditional public education. It's an
attempt to empower educators and an
invitation to create the kinds of
schools that we need in the 21st century.
To learn more about my take on school
choice, check the links in the
description below. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like a AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds.